[Musik]
die fregatte das war tagwache mitgehen
vor zwei jahren hat man das
österreichische bundesheer gesagt ich
soll wieder einrücken
ich hätte nie gedacht was das für ein
abenteuer sein wird ich darf euch
einladen dieses abenteuer mit mir noch
einmal zu erleben
mit einem tor und an diesem foto davon
gehirn benutzt habt das habe ich immer
total gefreut wenn der neue folge
gekommen ist das war die erste folge
richtig sehen dann habe ich mir gedacht
vielleicht entdeckt nicht hollywood ob
ich mir auch gedacht habe es mir
vielleicht bescheid wenn ich wenn ich
während der drehs den bauch einziehen
also keine namen vor allem bei der
mannschaft das war ja ihre unglaubliche
leid sie jeder jeder superhero das war
nicht gemeint
der typ der da habe ich wenn ich gewusst
hätte was was wir für mich bereithält
wäre wahrscheinlich auf der stelle
hinter nächsten bauausschuss die haben
ja auch caro gegeben wenn ich geglaubt
habe okay jetzt habe ich mich körperlich
genug verausgabt dann haben sie das
ganze verfahren begonnen und über das
was nicht dort machen wir müssen während
der dreharbeiten lachen die iren oder
das machen wie hoch 10 und das jeden tag
es betreut werden üblich ist hat
vergessen diesen oder jenen tag müssen
wir noch einmal machen echt gemein wenn
das beim sport passiert das was panorama
und der schweiz der nicht einmal da wir
dann habe ich die flex tragen dürfen
oder
die juli vor zwei jahren raus schalten
irgendwann komplett getrennt das war für
mich das erste mal bei offener türe in
einem helikopter wo ich meine damit dass
das was da jetzt auf dich zukommt das
wird das abenteuer schlechthin und das
war auch ganz interessant weil diese
situation zum stürmen dieses hauses wenn
du da drin steckst klar ist es nur in
filmen und klar weißt du es ist jetzt
nicht recht aber in dieser sekunde wenn
du da drinnen bist hast du echt das
gefühl es geht also wirklich eingemachte
und und es kommt auch sowas auch wie
extremer stress angst bei mir bei denen
halt nicht
dass das heißt ich schon ziemlich mit
apropos mitreißen
das war sicherlich dass beschäftigte
oder eine der heftigsten geschichten da
am helikopter zu hängen und durch die
landschaft zu fliegen
für ihre oma meine absolute
lieblingsstrecke die runde marke hunde
nur die tricks die drauf haben muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen sind wir dann
lustig wenn du hier bist und nicht wenn
auf der anderen seite schließlich große
tradition was ja schon einige frisur
schauinsland mit sicherheit einer der
absolut lustigsten szenen die ganz
jungen rekruten mit dieser köter
irgendwie alle sind natürlich
schwanzwedelnd es gibt schon gar nicht
um mich er hat so ziemlich alles gemacht
nun hat das was ihr wollt ob der mich
noch erkennt wahrscheinlich noch
sprengstoff es war ein heißer tag das
outfit das sie mir da angezogen haben
war nicht unbedingt lustig aber du
hättest auch noch gerne einen helm dazu
du versuchst zu lächeln und irgendwie
kultur schauen wir die kamera dabei und
man würde dastehen wie ein feigling
aber es gibt reis und zwar ordentlich
ist
oh ja die geöffnete luft aber so ich
muss ehrlicherweise gestehen ich habe
natürlich flugangst aber immer so ein
bisschen gutes gefühl ist halt dabei
man versucht sich selbst zu retten was
für ein abenteuer aber wenn du so in der
schrägen plötzlich hängst du knapp über
den boden mit einer irrwitzigen
geschwindigkeit fliegst gehört für die
zum täglichen brot die beherrschen das
natürlich auch perfekt aber es passiert
jeder sollte wissen wir aushalten kommt
ich hab mir da nicht mehrheitlich
funktioniert das war für mich einer der
momente echte herausforderung weil ich
muss ehrlich gestehen man sieht ja egal
wer da an bis unterkante oberkiefer und
versucht dabei ausgeschlossen
und da jetzt beinahe einen unfall
gegeben weil ich habe nämlich dann über
mich besser sieht dass mein helm
verzichtet der normalerweise natürlich
da immer dabei ist ja klar
und da waren sie echt ist kein helm und
ihr doch danach beinahe man sieht's ganz
gut im bild mit dem schädel an die mauer
geduscht
ich hänge hier bleibe ich bin auf den
letzten metern weg zu stehen
die binde anhaben können das sind
trainings für den ernstfall und das
bekommst du das schon mit bekommt damit
das spiel aber oftmals ein spaß gehabt
haben und viel gelacht haben es schaut
ein bisschen aus weil ich halte auch
völlig fehl am platz wie spielern spaß
im wald aber du merkst an den
soldatinnen soldaten und an der
ernsthaftigkeit mit der sie der
unterwegs sind
dass das ist training für den ernstfall
das war er also jetzt kann man sagen
ausschaut hat das nicht schlecht
es hat ausgeschaut wie beim salatbuffet
aber es war so ekelhaft
man denkt sich ja gut wald und wiese
kräuter ich meine da kann man sicher was
was gutes zusammenstellen
das hat ekelhaft geschmückt war aber
angeblich sehr sehr lehrreich ach ja
dann farbe auflegen heißt
herrscht und lang versuchen das zeigt
wieder runter zu kriegen um ein grad
das ist eine truppe warf eine längere es
ist blöd wenn es erst bei andré wie
diesen draufkommt dass du ein problem
mit mir hast
ich bin da oben gestanden und habe mir
gedacht und was wenn jetzt der das seit
heute oder was ist mein von oben das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt das was du wo du
dich besonders sicher fühlst
wir haben also genug mitgenommen
das rauf klettern war nicht das problem
da habe ich sogar das gefühl gehabt die
stelle ganz so deppert an den ausstand
aber oben das abseilen das war übel
so und jetzt kommt der springende punkt
die haben das vorher nicht gesagt
normalerweise fahre ich immer so was
steht als nächstes an worauf musst du
dich selig vorbereiten aber diesem
moment war wirklich schwierig aber das
ganze geschäft mit boxing wir aus dem
schier wieder raus und dann dann hänge
ich kopfüber nach unten aber ich war
heilfroh ob ich da unten angekommen bin
in einer eishöhle gar nicht ungemütlich
hat was meint ihr tempo zusammen also
dass du tust du denkst ok wird dieses so
weit jetzt friere ich aber drinnen
plötzlich wird es dann nicht mehr nicht
um den claus schick aber zumindest bist
du safe und selber sprengungen auslösen
das ist für den buben in mir ein ganz
besonderer moment gewesen
aus dem zimmer weil ich glaube mein
letzter sprechen war ein schwarzer rauch
hat das silvester vor 20 jahren
das hatte ihm wie ein
damals lernte ich wollte eigentlich
selber von mit dem teil aber als mann
entlassen
das hat mich immer wieder viele gefragt
was war das geilste und da fällt mir die
wahl schwer wo ich das gefühl gehabt
hab' ich kann mir jetzt ein trauma für
ihn war selber einzufahren schon einmal
ganz groß im moment der für mich an
dieser stelle merke ich bereits das wird
mein tag schaut cool aus und ist es
drinnen sitzt es ist noch ein bisschen
lauter als rumpelig nie wieder parkplatz
suchen
durch das tier einfach darauf auf den
andern und stau gibt es keinen mehr
natürlich muss man schon aufgegeben
das denke ich kann das lustigerweise am
öftesten zurück also diese dieser
eindruck der eisenbahn sitzen und selber
das team fahren zu dürfen
deshalb verständlich unter kundiger
anleitung ich war schon besonders
nein eigentlich als folge war dass die
flieger ja es ist wahr dass auch die
kampf das ist schon was ganz ganz
besonderes und ich bin selber
leidenschaftlicher taucher oder dass das
was ich unter tauchen verstehe und das
was die herrschaften da untertauchen
verstehen wenig miteinander zu tun hat
wusste ich ja zu dem zeitpunkt und auf
einmal wird aus einem einem schönen
hobby extrem fordern wenn auch
sicherlich sehr abenteuerlich und
spannender job und du lernst fernsehshow
respekt und zwar schon im swimmingpool
ich glaube ich habe immer was davon in
der lunge
oh ja auch dieser stressfaktor wenn du
diesen hält dann auf fast da gibt es die
sind ganz kurzen moment bevor sie den
luft überhaupt erst einmal aufdrehen
also alles nicht unspannend in einer
tauchausrüstung aus dem black hawk zu
springen in einem fluss das erleben
nicht viele menschen
und jetzt kommt ein ganz wichtiger
moment ja genau
wir haben diesen tag mehrere male
aufgenommen wenn du ein springst aus dem
helikopter solltest du geradeaus schauen
damit du gerade ein tauchst bei einem
einzigen mal habe ich darauf vergessen
wir haben es ja immer und immer wieder
gedreht
und das habe ich voll auf die bank auf
der wasseroberfläche für den film
was hat sie genommen genau da ist
abgenommen dass das einzige mal wo ich
wo ich es nicht geschafft habe
elegant einzutauchen danke dafür ganz
herzlich man schaut er einfach elegant
aus neopren
da kann man sagen was man will das
bundesheer hat natürlich seine
traditionen diese taufe ist eine davon
und wir wollten natürlich auch diese
traditionen mitteilen
wie man sieht ich bin sehr dankbar das
ist ja das ist elite einheit und das
letzte was die herrschaften dort
gebraucht haben weil jemand wie ich
jetzt eröffnen terroristen feuerwehr
faltet mich zusammen wie ein blatt
papier
aber natürlich bekommt also dass neben
nichts passiert und dass mein leben
geschützt ist und dann geht's ab durch
die mitte
und eines wurde mir vorher nicht gesagt
dass ich auch immer wieder von der
situation überrascht worden bin und
authentisch zu reagieren wir zum
beispiel einfach erstklassig und große
zuschauer neben die eine firma
exportiert
das können wir bieten nahkampf da habe
ich nur einmal richtig gezeigt dass ich
nichts kann
selbstverteidigung als wirklich dazu in
der lage gewesen und wisse dass ich da
manchmal in am abend beim einschlafen
genau über diese szene nachdenkt ich
versuche mich daran zu erinnern was man
mir beibringen wollte ja da wie ist es
gegangen normal
wir haben das nicht merkt jetzt wieder
eine erbärmliche vorstellung um
einerseits den gras gefressen
trotz gibt es erwärmt sich aus das sehr
richtig übel
der verdammte bayern hat aber wie gut
machte man muss auch dazu sagen ein
kamerateam hat natürlich bei solchen
aufnahmen dann den größten spaß gehabt
für all meine freiheiten für das
oftmalige zuspätkommen zu dreharbeiten
und ähnlichen dingen das waren die
momente wo sie sich dann alle gedacht
haben recht ich sehe das jetzt erst
wieder reinschaut
wenn mein flug trainer sondern nach dem
motto was haben sie man da einige selbst
ins cockpit um ein grad tonnen rolle und
co bei den dreharbeiten haben sich von
der kammer frau bis zum regisseur immer
alle gefragt bei welcher serviert er
ohnmächtig wo wir da angst kriegen wo
wir komplett versagen
das war einer dieser momente das sieht
sich wetten abgeschlossen worden werde
ich ohnmächtig oder nicht
und man merkt hier
der stressfaktor steigt jemand eines
vorgenommen gehabt hat es in tagen hat
das mit einem stoßgebet richtung himmel
geschickt
sind bei aller liebe lassen wir nicht
ins cockpit bleiben ich glaube ich hatte
ihn jeder dass meine uniform die die
anforderungen körperlich als auch
geistig werden da der immer höher und
für mich immer unerreichbar
das ist das einzige was sie wirklich
authentisch immer gut rübergebracht hat
wenn mich in das verschlafen zu spät
kommen
das war die letzte folge die wir gedreht
haben und wir haben gedacht ab diesel
was habe ich wohl mitgenommen
all den ich werde mir hat jetzt das
heute österreichische bundesheer durch
ich dachte ich hätte viel gelernt sie es
ist vollkommen egal übrigens wie alt du
wirst in dem augenblick wurde ich
jemanden eine tafel steht
bist du einfach wieder 15 und fühlt sich
auch genauso aber das gesicht des
lehrers in diesem fall kenne ich auch
von meiner eigenen schulzeit noch eine
mischung zwischen zwischen verachtung
und mittlere besondere szene jetzt wird
ziemlich gleich etwas sagen hören er
einen satz meine schluss kompanie k2
unterstützung durch den zuzug ganze
kreative zu meinem buch und als er sehr
viel
der gepanzerte jägerzug und diesen satz
zu sagen habe halbe stunde angelernt
auswendig gelernt
zwei jahre waren das jetzt tag war schon
mitglied der unglaublich aufregenden
dreharbeiten für mich ich möchte mich in
aller erster linie mal bedankt bedanken
bei so vielen die mitgeholfen haben das
ganze überhaupt möglich geworden ist
bedanken aber vorrecht bei den
eigentlichen hauptdarsteller mit
hauptdarstellern nehme ich den
soldatinnen und soldaten dann gerne sagt
kommando an die weltcup turniere an das
militär oder zertifikate von
luftstreitkräften die gebirgsjäger das
panzerbataillon 14-jährige partie auf 25
danke an die abc abwehr die heeres
taucher die militärpolizei die band zu
können die er die aufklärung der
artillerie danke an das überwachungs
geschwader an die logistik und danke an
die soldatinnen soldaten mit der
militärakademie die weitergemeldet sich
ab ich wünsche ihm alles gute
[Musik]